[Music]
welcome to this episode of vme end to
end uh where you have a vm
enthusiast and a former vm skeptic so
now you have two vm enthusiasts talking
about all things vm related brian
welcome to the show i'm i'm super
excited and a little bashful to have you
here today
likewise so you're you're convinced like
sweet you have convinced me i you know
what i clow vms seem relevant they seem
useful they seem a lot of fun so i guess
what i want to know is
how do i get started do i have to travel
back in time find a dusty manual
somewhere blow it off look up
instructions if i want to use this where
do i go what do i do
come on man
we're in the cloud now right so um it's
a web world so you know i think the
great place to start is on the web so
there's a cloud console at
cloud.google.com that is a website you
know that you can manage all cloud and
in there
uh compute engine so i think it's a
really good place um to see what's
possible to explore learn get some
visualizations on what's going on with
with the machines
and there there is a command line though
if if someone like might be a little
more okay just check it
tell me about it yeah i know you want to
you want to go for efficiency and
automation
well like there's definitely a command
line
and it uses the same api behind the
scenes do they interact with each other
at all are they just two separate tools
with the same api
so they're primarily separate tools um
but there's some neat kind of
bootstrapping stuff um
at you know one high level is there's a
there's actually a command line embedded
in the web ui so you can you know hit a
button
and and get a you know command line
interface off of actually a little vm
that we run for you um but in addition
to that any of the compute engine pages
you're on when you go to like say create
a new vm fill out a bunch of things make
a bunch of decisions if you scroll the
bottom there's a link to get the exact
gcloud
syntax that would do the same thing as
you just set up in the web oh that's
very cool then you could go into that
like web shell and use it all right i i
can see
how that could be useful like very
useful
one of the things i'm wondering about is
i come from again like container world
right and i'm used to using something
like docker where i can declaratively
say this is what i want my image to look
like uh you know i want to have this
layer i want to have this set of tooling
is there anything like that for vms or
google vms absolutely um and you know
in particular people use a lot of
terraform for that but i want to take a
step back that some of the things people
do on vms are kind of manual and you
know for a long live vm
you know a manual setup and take some
backups
that is a a reasonable thing to do for
for a you know one-off um
but as soon as you start having you know
you know multiple copies of that or a
more complex setup you you start wanting
automation right so um
there are multiple different tools that
use the same apis to create vms and
configure the networking and the like um
in particular terraform is very very
common um i think it's also worth
checking out pulling me
and you know both of those will let you
set up a configuration declare how you
want things to look and push that out
and
part of the reason i think this is so
important so it's important for
production to be able to like make
things consistent right but
in addition to that
testing is really hard like
almost nobody can afford to run a full
test environment that's the size of
production and in physical machines it
as far as i know almost never happens um
but
if you have things automated you can run
a test of a smaller number of machines
or the same number of machines for a
shorter amount of time for way less
money you know you can be talking like
one percent or parts of a percent of of
what it cost to run a production and do
a completely valid test in the same
environment using the same tools so
that's really powerful
oh wow that that's really cool and i've
actually seen that pattern a lot in
kubernetes i talk about kubernetes a lot
because that's my context
but in kubernetes you have this ability
to automate what happens when you do
certain actions so if i wanted to
release some code and have it go to a
small staging area before it went out
fully to production you could do that
and and what i'm hearing tell me if i'm
wrong here but it sounds like you can do
that same thing but on a different scale
uh you might be able to do that with
your entire cloud infrastructure using
you know some of the tooling you're
talking about yeah that's pretty much it
so you know people use things like
terraform to
you know
declare the setup of things like
including a kubernetes cluster itself
maybe buckets you know for storage maybe
a database um some vms like i mentioned
and you've got your entire setup you
know all scripted out and repeatable
ready to go see that's that's amazing
and this is one of the reasons why i'm
i'm happy that i've been convinced
something i am curious about though is
if i already have my own system uh maybe
i switch over to vms from on-prem i have
my own way of accessing my my my my
workloads my vms all of that can i still
do it uh for instance if i had like an
ssh keys i was using those to access my
system can i still use those on google
cloud absolutely
and this gets back to like the vm is
just a computer so like and it's the
most compatible thing we have in cloud
so if you can do it on a computer
because they're extremely good you can
do it on a vm so yes you can log in with
just user accounts and passwords you can
log in with ssh keys
whatever you've normally been doing
for ssh keys we have a couple of things
to help out a bit so if you've got you
know automation you've been using you
can keep doing that for managing keys
we also have a way where you can push
keys up into the project level and have
them be available um on the vms
and
if you're not running something like
that
you're already logging into google cloud
with a google account so you can
essentially delegate the rights to log
into a machine and then we will create
the ssh keys to make that happen and
make it work
wow so there's a lot of power there um
i guess okay so there's flexibility i
can use tooling i already know
at this point there's really nothing
that's leaving me or stopping me from
signing up and using this and then i
guess i just i don't know i said it i
let it run i get the promo i win the day
i drive off in a nice car right
it's all done all done you know software
doesn't work that way right like
things change you know like the context
around it you've got new versions you
know maybe the load changes up and down
that sort of thing um yeah so things
change and i think you know some of the
stuff we've talked about already helps
with that so when you talk about groups
of machines and a managed instance group
getting bigger and smaller that helps
with uh load changes over time
um if if we decide to do some work like
some planned work on uh the host machine
or um you know the kernel needs an
update or something like that we'll do a
live migration to move the vm to another
machine with no downtime and then do
that work
that's transparent tell me how it sounds
like
exactly so that'll help with some
changes that need to happen at the data
center level and then you know when
changes happen to your software you know
you'll need to update it and do versions
so if you've got a system you're already
using for that you know you can probably
continue doing that um another pattern
that i think is
um pretty common in cloud but not other
places is you you build up the whole
disk image including the software
and then call that version a and then
you build up another disk image with a
new version of software called that
version b and then you can kind of
rotate that into one of these groups and
upgrade that way and if something goes
wrong you can just go back to the old
image
this is why i'm convinced because
all of these features that you're
talking about are the features that i
was like oh this is why i love
kubernetes it's so easy to use it's like
it's all of them are in the vm world so
i i i strongly believe that most of the
the advantages you know we we get from
kind of a cloud native architecture and
that sort of thing can be done in vms on
the cloud so
that
brings that uh those features those
abilities to workloads that you know
might be a lot of work to migrate or
require coordination with another team
that may not exist anymore or with an
external company or something you can't
do and so you can get a bunch of the
same
benefits uh to those workloads as well
wow so i've like i said at the very
beginning of the episode i'm convinced
i'm gonna go try this and if you're
watching this at home one thank you so
much for watching us talk about vms for
six episodes but two go and try this out
and then
brian
you've kind of led the direction of the
conversation so far what we need to talk
about next where do you think we should
go from here at this point so i think
you know we've hit a pretty good
baseline you know of of like
fundamentals but i think where we go
next really depends where people want it
to go so
i would love if folks who who watched
this long again thank you um commented
you know below to say you know here's
what i'd love to learn more about what
i'd love to go deeper on um you know i'd
like to see an example of or could you
bring in another expert to talk about
something those kinds of things so let's
do that if you're watching this at home
leave a comment below tell us what we
should explore next like i don't know
security or any other topics and we'll
take a look and see where we're going to
go in the future thanks again for
watching that's the end of this season
and that's the end of vme and the end
for now thanks brian
[Music]
you